Please welcome the absolutely beautiful, Iris Apatow.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Thank you.
You know, I met your sister Jud and Leslie,
Jud was doing some writing on the Wedding Singer.
Oh yeah.
And I met your sister when she was a baby.
I know, I know.
We've all just watched--
You've watched us grow up.
I mean, I like, literally have felt--
Like when I was growing up, people like,
oh you like a little drew Barry Barrymore,
So I started copying you
for my whole life, which sounds creepy.
But I literally have like copied--
Like even this is like your niche,
like dark hair from the nineties.
And I was like, yeah, I'll do that one too.
Like, you know what?
We actually pulled a couple images
literally us hair twining right there.
There is one.
Oh my goodness.
I love this. God, you're so stunning.
There's another--
Oh my God.
Look at us.
(audience applauding and cheering)
It's funny because you know,
your sister has really like come
into the forefront in Euphoria.
Like I'm like, oh my God,
I feel like the entire show's becoming about her.
I know it's--
I'm not such a style trend setter.
I mean, can you believe the influence
that the show has had on hair, makeup,
wardrobe, all of it.
Oh yeah.
Like immediately when it came out,
I remember like me and my friends
would put like gems all over our eyes before parties.
And like it changed everything, which is so cool.
And it's-- I remember like when my sister
would call me from her trailer
I would screenshot every look
just to like copy it before it came out.
to make me look original.
It's called inspo for a reason.
Exactly.
But do you like the show?
I love the show.
That's like my favorite show.
Me and my friends, like,
do watch parties for it every weekend.
You do?
Or when it was out, we did, yeah.
We were-- Oh my God.
You mean like you and your bestie, Olivia Rodrigo?
(audience applauding and cheering)
Okay, what do I need to know about Olivia Rodrigo
through her best friend's eyes?
Teach me.
Well we-- Well we live together, so we do--
Okay, this must be the coolest house in all of the planet.
We have Sex in the City movie nights.
I mean, it just makes me happy.
It's like one of those things.
I also loved the reboot.
I was-- I loved it.
I wish-- I hope it comes back for season two.
I hope it does too.
I miss Kim Cattrall, bring her back.
Me too.
It's so sad that she's not on it.
What are the odds of her coming back?
She's coming back.
They're-- They can't hide it from us,
I know she's coming back.
I want it. Let's go on a campaign.
Come on, Kim Cattrall--
Petition--
(audience applauding)
All right, so you have this lovely boyfriend,
you're out there in the world.
Ryder Robinson,
who is just so delightful and charming.
What are you guys up to?
How's that going?
And oh, just, I'm so excited.
It's going very well.
We have been together for a while
and he's just like been such like a lovely angel in my life.
It's very refreshing when you grow up
in high school and just like dating around,
like I had my fair share of weirdos,
so it's nice to come to somebody
that just wants you to be happy and like you know,
seeing what can be healthy is really nice.
Very, very refreshing.
And he makes me very happy and I love him a lot.
I'm so happy for you.
Thanks.
You're so happy.
Your parents have been such couple goals to all of us.
Yeah, no, I think they're very like much
so like what I look for in my love life
because they'll just sit together for like four hours
just talking and I'm like,
wow what are you guys talking about?
It's like, it's nice to see that
like after however many years, 25 or something
they can still, you know, make each other laugh that hard
and be like best friends with each other.
(audience applauding)
That is the example.
Yeah, that's--
That is the goal.
What I like look for, I guess.
You're a teenager or are a full blown grownup
if we could just be nice to each other--
Exactly.
So tell me about The Bubble,
this is another family affair.
Courtesy of the Apatows.
Yes.
The Bubble follows some actors shooting a movie--
In a bubble.
In a bubble in London.
So they basically like live
in this beautiful English countryside castle
and are like having people serve them.
And they're just kind of self-centered
and like bratty I guess is the word.
They're just like, it's--
You know how it could-- Everything that could go wrong
when making a movie during, you know, lockdown.
Then I think that's what makes it kind of silly
'cause there's humor to be found in that
and you know, isolation
but mostly just because of their behavior
and how it's so bad.
(upbeat music)